y el oído humano puede escuchar
frecuencias que van desde lo más bajo
que son 20 hertz
hasta la mayor frecuencia que está
alrededor de 20.000 hertz
esto es el rango de lo que podemos
escuchar pero si hay frecuencias mayores
a estas les damos un nombre especial que
es el de ultrasonido ultrasonido
y esto hace más que molestar a los
perros y a otros animales esto tiene un
propósito práctico si queremos obtener
imágenes del cuerpo humano para conocer
lo que sucede dentro de él imaginemos
que esto es una porción del cuerpo
humano y por acá tenemos un órgano vital
por aquí tenemos otro tejido y nos
preocupa que algo malo esté ocurriendo
aquí podríamos operar pero él no es muy
bueno no queremos lastimar el tejido
también podríamos sacar rayos equis pero
demasiada exposición a los rayos x es
dañina una muy buena opción es el
ultrasonido vamos a poner aquí un
transductor lo ponemos junto a la piel y
este transductor
transductor
este va a funcionar con energía
eléctrica lo enchufábamos a la pared y
este aparatito va a transformar esa
energía eléctrica en ondas de sonido así
que aquí vamos a emitir ondas de sonido
este transductor va a enviar un pulso y
este pulso va a viajar a través de esto
y cuando llegue a esto se va a reflejar
se va a reflejar siempre que encuentre
un material diferente al del medio que
se encuentra aquí siempre y cuando haya
una interferencia entre estos dos medios
para hacerlo sencillo digamos que esto
café es tejido de algún órgano y lo que
está en rojo es la sangre por ejemplo
esto va a ir viajando va a ir viajando y
en el momento que se encuentre una
interfase diferente en el medio en el
que estaba viajando se va a reflejar se
va a reflejar hacia acá y este
transductor tiene tiempo sabe en qué
momento lanzó la señal y captura el
momento en el que se refleja también
conoce la velocidad del sonido y puede
hacer cálculos
si esto salió en este momento y está lo
cierto tiempo en reflejarse aquí quiere
decir que esto viajó cierta distancia y
por lo tanto hay algo aquí y esto no
termina aquí de hecho buena parte de
este sonido va a seguir viajando por acá
por acá hasta que se encuentra otra
interfase que es la diferencia entre el
tejido y la sangre por lo que esto se va
a reflejar de nuevo esto ocurre en otro
momento y el transductor toma nota de
ello por lo que se da cuenta que aquí
hay algo ya que aquí hubo un reflejo en
este primer rayo y lo que siguió también
se reflejó en esta parte de nuevo así
que aquí hay algo pero aquí tampoco
termina la cosa esto sigue viajando por
acá hasta que llegue a este punto a este
cambio en la interfase y se vuelve a
reflejar
hacia acá y estoy dibujando estas ondas
de sonido para que las puedan ver aunque
en realidad estarían una encima de la
otra aquí toma nota que ha pasado otra
cantidad de tiempo y esto continúa así
el transductor va a ir detectando los
puntos que hay de diferencia de
interfaces y esto nos va a dar una
imagen transversal el transductor va a
estar enviando sus ondas de sonido o
pulsos a través de toda esta superficie
del transductor de manera que pueda
detectar todos estos puntos y al final
formar una imagen
exacta de lo que se encuentra aquí y así
poder conocer qué es lo que pasa o qué
es lo que hay aquí adentro y esta es una
aplicación práctica del ultrasonido se
usa en frecuencias de ultrasonido para
hacer esto y quizá ustedes se pregunten
bueno por qué tenemos que usar
ultrasonido bueno una razón es que si
usamos los rangos de frecuencia que
podemos escuchar en lugar del
ultrasonido pues este paciente al que se
le aplique este aparatito va a decir y
de verdad creen que deberían estar
haciéndome esto ya que esto podría ser
bastante molesto y otra razón práctica
para usar el ultrasonido es que las
altas frecuencias
las altas frecuencias o lo que es lo
mismo
las bajas longitudes de onda
esto es lo mismo recuerden que la
rapidez de una onda es igual a la
longitud de la onda por la frecuencia si
la frecuencia es alta la longitud de
onda debe ser baja y esto es igual a la
velocidad y la velocidad no está
determinada por ninguno de estos la
velocidad está determinada por el medio
en el que viaja la onda y resulta que
para altas frecuencias y bajas
longitudes de onda vamos a tener una
menor difracción
y recordemos que la difracción es el
enemigo de las imágenes claras ya que la
difracción es la propagación de las
ondas imaginemos que por aquí viene una
onda y esta onda se encuentra con una
barrera vamos a imaginar que es esta al
llegar la onda aquí si es una de alta
frecuencia se va a propagar pero se va a
propagar - va a pasar por este agujero
se va a propagar un poquito haciéndose
un poquito más ancha pero si fuera una
onda de baja frecuencia o que estuviera
en el rango auditivo o tuviera una
longitud de onda mayor la propagación
sería mucho mayor y esto sería un
problema ya que imaginemos lo que
pasaría imaginemos que aquí va nuestra
onda
y aquí se empieza a dispersar oa
propagar y lo que hace otra cosa que
hace la difracción es que hace que las
ondas puedan girar alrededor de las
esquinas ocurre la difracción y ahora
tenemos todas estas ondas de sonido que
se están doblando estas cosas no se van
a estar reflejando bien y sólo van a
confundir al transductor por lo que al
final tendremos una imagen borrosa y es
por eso que preferimos usar el
ultrasonido ya que desde alta frecuencia
y por lo mismo tiene una menor
difracción esto nos dará una mejor
imagen y ese es una de las aplicaciones
del ultrasonido para propósitos médicos